salut à tous et pêchant de 13 ans alors
comme vous l'avez deviné non le titre de
la vidéo aujourd'hui on est au cap
d'agde voilà ce qu'on va faire je pense
quand un vrai coeur des trouvailles
plutôt exotique c'est le but nous on a
mis nos tenues de travail adéquat des
lieux c'est comme ça par contre on est
en hiver donc sympa thomas on n'est pas
à la bonne saison
à tous par mois allez on attaque la
pêche alors là premier lancer et j'ai
déjà quelque chose dégâts
mais sans
nom il est ouvert
aux mains c'est bon tu ignores qui
étaient venus pour l'occasion c'est bien
bon jour il peut réserver des surprises
mais on voit un peu le fond de l'eau
donc normalement bon n'y aura pas de
choses énormes aie sa part
alors vous constatez on a dû travailler
parce qu'en fait avec les piercings
c'est pas possible avec les miens c'est
trop dangereux pour protéger vraiment
les personnes dotées ton de tintin et au
plus vif au passage à vide et aux petits
as moi j'ai un truc
cette partie là ça me fait vraiment
penser à un chargeur c'est un chargeur
c'est un chargeur du coup c'est quoi ça
pistolet à blanc ou même pistolet à
bille habits je pense ouais ouais
pistolet à bille sa belle trouvaille en
tout cas
il ya peut-être le pistolet avec ben
j'ai quelque chose au bac s annonce un
poste à poste à dommage tu vois que
l'eau de mer salée
défrichèrent alors mettre les mollusques
dans l'eau
ouais
au
encore un cadenas avec un antivol il est
énorme
allez je suis laotien
enfin pas
engager une pièce
j'ai du franc
crois que c'est
un ou deux francs
qu'est ce que vous avez trouvé
ça mais c'est un cône de signalisation
battant on peut peut-être les deux et
man ouest dernier par le bout par en
haut je crois que je suis presque dans
ce cas l'autonomie on a peut-être
l'impression attend vos esprits
aïe on voit la réussite par la réussite
je suis des pays les
plus gros modèles ouais tu le mets sur
ta tête tu la côte et quand est tout nu
en
attendant guy
même au travers c'est super dur
ouais belle trouvaille bravo
bien trouvé
un panneau
où il est plein de 9 de poisson
à l'arrivée une anémone y en a deux
ouais bah étoiles de mer
ah ouais c'est de tout remettre à l'eau
comme ça j'ai entendu tout cas
précis
n'ont
peut-être que c'est ça les jeunes
non
le protoxyde d azote c'est la drogue le
gaz hilarant
ouais
ouais c'est terrible
ça du coup je te l'offre si tu veux elle
est presque presque comme
[Musique]
9,1 j'ai quelque chose moi aussi
encore un couteau au lit tôt c'est un
skateboard
c'est trop cool hein
c'est à peine énoncée dans les roues et
en vue du camp
et les tout petits
[Applaudissements]
non il a failli tomber dans l'eau
sort un drame ouais alors dans le vin
compris entre toutes les mains ouais ou
là
c'est un siège non
une chaise de pêcheurs
est donc un pied
voilà voilà elle est plus belle comme ça
ouais super la petite pêche dans le port
maintenant
alors péri quelque chose non mais
peut-être ça accroche pas en fait
on va attraper tous les deux un côté
québécois on
michael tu peux te baisser un style va
t'aider est inquiète
voilà allez sauvetage dans le port au
wawel est la panacée
mais c'est super
d'accord
impeccable
vous le voulez le skate ou pas non tout
ça vous fait ça vous fait un souvenir
comme ça ouais ça nous fait plaisir
alors changement de peau ici à une boîte
de nuit à bas location de jet ski ce
quartier karting et tout ça ça peut être
sympa déjà on avait un gros panneau là
donc or si on va pouvoir l'attraper
direct où il est lourd
la trappe et oui
alors vous pensez que c'est un panneau
où il ya écrit quoi dessus moi je dirais
limite à 101 ans les 8 à 500 euros je
pense que c'est un truc en rapport avec
le corps et à la pêche interdit de
pêcher peut-être ça serait bien ça
interdit depuis
a il avait raison ouais c'est ce truc
bien joué regarde ça c'est des autres
c'est ce poisson possède pas le crever
mais c'est hyper dur c'est mort ouais
c'est impossible ah non c'est bon
ouais mais pas trop mais bien jouer à la
meinau alors ouais ça va il n'y avait
pas trop de vie aquatique il est pas
très vieux s'il a
bien joué
je fais quoi rasta je fais les bêtises
encore tu montes n'importe où
1 j'ai quelque chose au
ce que serait pas un chargeur
mais très très très très vieux
un tas
rien j'ai un truc au nom
protoxyde d'azoté
au
sein pas dos
et servat
et s'est enfui
à tuer bien sûr c'est un joli panneau
ok c'est encore coincés
je le vois le truc ebook qu'il est tout
petit voilà
c'est vraiment une
belle et cela
au
joli ça
c'est quoi ça c'est du dinar dirhams
[Musique]
vous avez quelque chose
ouais mais tu as fini par l'avoir le
truc de thaler là ce que je te disais
c'est bizarre mais il veut pas sortir de
la science va
compliquer
attendait non mais vous avez peur de
faire mal
c'est bon
tu attends s'enlever de la pression
maintenant qu'on est comme ça en fait
c'est galère parce qu'il est un membre
ou you to c'est difficile à gratter
parce que ça va être une sorte de table
il ya que le bord qui en faire on a des
gars voient
on nettoiera ça on est en face à pouvoir
il ya peut-être un dessin là tu vois on
verra
sa fin un grand merci à killian lydia et
yanis pour nous avoir accompagnés pour
la paix chez nous ont bien aidé aussi
wells avait occupé de rasta
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle ville de pecz aliments la
prochaine fois on risque d'aller dans un
spot qui sera beaucoup plus
prolifique on sera pas au
top
baba toi alors l'objectif c'est
d'apprendre à faire du skate
voilà plutôt sympa